you
I was muted that whole fucking time I was muted that whole fucking time
I was yapping away singing away I was like hi I'm just turning my light on I'm in
a dark room oh fuck sake okay good morning you know why it's such a good
morning I slept 11 hours so no I did no background work I'm sorry to the girls
had spiked me had spiked me you know I apologize disly disly so whenever I go
outside it's rather draining and and I went to the dentist and I got the
thumbs up from my dentist she's so lovely she was like oh wait you've been
getting up to study and I was like start a business the last time I saw you and
she's like oh what do you do and I was like oh I tea obviously I tell her I'm
a voice actress and I don't like keep it above board you know keep a book 50
and and I was like oh I started a business but you know obviously with
everything when you do it for the first time there's like headaches or sass on
she's like oh that's a shame I was like telling her all the fun parts and she's
like I've actually been to Edinburgh recently but obviously she was in my
mouth so all I could go is and I forgot to say like oh did you enjoy Edinburgh
but yeah I've got the thumbs up my teeth are good to go so I get to go back in
six months to get another clean then cuz they clean my teeth and they put
polish and them like they put like banana sweet polish on my teeth and it's
still in between my teeth and she just says leave alone and I'm like I find I
leave alone but I fell asleep for 11 hours and it's still there go away I'm
just currently replying to the girls on Twitter I'm I'm needing to fucking be
more social towards them and I'm fucking failing so it's like energy pro
congrats I'm replying to Mercedes I'm gonna go on a season I've replied to
everyone so that like a social being I do love my daughters oh my god she
got head she actually did I see has a artwork of her being a dog and actually
looks really fucking cute head pass you gently but firm head pass you gently but
firmly this is so cute I'll leave a little blue heart
she's a blue I buddy I would have had past you gently but for me
right there we go I've never applied to all my gen mates no one can say that I'm
on social publicly because obviously we talk behind the scenes but no one can
say we're not thinking okay right we are playing a little game called Pikmin
no this is the gospel I have played this game once in my life in the hospital
when they thought I had appendicitis but it was actually my first anxiety
she's starting a gastro distress okay so my perception of this game is
absolutely agony going on in my abdomen but I still played it anyway and the
fucking nurses are cheeky weebams so there is fuck all to do in the hospital
and obviously I open up the cabinet like there was kids gaming on it and I sat
in game I took all the kids off it so I could play the one level and Pikmin
that I could complete over and over again because I got stuck because I was a
child okay but like this is when like the Nintendo DS was out the Xbox was out
the PlayStation was out and obviously technology takes a while to catch up in
a fucking child's hospital and I was like what ancient technology is this and
I'm like pretty sure it was like a Nintendo 64 or something I had never
like the the system thing I've never seen it in my life so I was like what is
this and I was like watching the other kids play it and then once they went away
I sat on that thing the entire fucking day so that's all no no I turned up for
you I didn't have appendicitis they made me like piss into a thing and it went
everywhere and I just remember it going everywhere on the floor and I had to
like clean up that for myself a game cube yeah I was like what is this this
doesn't look like an Xbox and the nurse was a cheeky wee sneaky so it was the
end of the night where she's like to close up the game like they have to close
up the cabinets in the hospital you've ever been in a once I only stayed two
nights or something and they were like now you're not your appendicitis and
burst and we don't know what's wrong when you go home and obviously looking back
I know it's exciting now but and before it was enough to put you in the hospital
yes I was an absolute agony my guts are twist my I'm the type where my guts twist
that's why I've got a lot of anxiety about taking a big fat massive dump okay
I don't care I'll say it how it is that's where my abomb manifests I don't
know how your abomb manifests that's how mine manifests okay it's around taking
the toilet and so she was like okay they're giving medicine so you need to go
back to your bed so went back to my bed took my medicine she feel a little
nurse she locked the cabinet so I couldn't keep playing Pikmin UV BAM but
it's probably good for me go to sleep at regular time but you know so this is
pick man I'm gonna make sure my controllers work in and praying it
doesn't crash because I'm using a real game cube right now so I'm gonna
verbalize as my pain bro it's all around the toilet for me actual shotgun
spray no it wasn't the game tube contemporary but I just never seen a
game cube before so when I saw it I was like what is that I still an expert
mind you I'm like a tiny wee wane I can hardly formulate sentences and I'm like
hmm something's not right here my gamer instincts are going off this isn't
correct this is the wrong technology and tricky nurse chicks yes the nurses
my low IQ child mind could not comprehend that she wanted to lock the
cabinet and do you want us to take her out no no not at all and where's violent
what ancient wizardry I was like I've ever seen such scriptures before and I
was like damn I can see every pixel on the screen what's literally what is this
purple square box what does it do right lemme hydrate I got my cup of tea
obviously believe it or not sleeping for 11 hours you get rather dehydrated
and that's I went for a pee and it was like the world's tiniest amount of pee
give me okay that's easy I might be lucky every time I spent the night in a
hospital I was for someone else I had that with my family I've never had to
spend the night though because I was very young when they became ill I had
sleepovers with my gran when she was sick but obviously I don't know if you
heard about the news and the old NHS they're siphoning the old money out of
it so it's hardly functioning hospitals are a unique area but I know a lot of
it's actually secretly reported that a lot of guys have a fear of the hospital
and but I don't know whether that's because a relative you saw someone or
your concept of the hospital isn't to get better it's where you go when you're
sick and you don't want to be sick and it's rather interesting why the fuck is
my game point oh no is it broken I can't even oh I mean I mean my my game cube
woke up yes oh my god what's up music oh oh hit him with it oh my god what is
this is this a tutorial am I watching the tutorial
picklings oh okay so we harvest I threw you at walls oh my god your little
leafs can take down walls you're that strong okay tell us how you really feel
pick man it's a mix also expensive it's a demo the old arcade creating a
Pikmin save file don't do it in hand right okay a Pikmin save files being
created ships log go for it new ships log oh my god I'm just gonna call it the
first time play through if you like that I remember anything about this game
alien alien confirmed for jim to oh a satellite dish in a little rotation on
the bottom we're going into someone's nose oh a meteor oh it's getting dramatic
was that the game cube doodly doodly doodly boom a reef min or a pickling I
think picklings because I always put Ling at the end of something oh no we're
crash landing oh it's getting dramatic I don't know about you the impact say
don't don't don't a green a gray or a glow I'm not giving someone green skin
appeal yeah look I'll say it I'll say it with my full chest knife ears green
skin alien I'll see how it is we are a fantasy racist around these parts my
name is captain olimar while traveling through space my ship was struck by me
I must have blacked out and I woke on the surface of this weird planet so with
so many parts lost the skeletal hull of my beloved dolphin is a painful sight
the engine is gone and I'm stranded to make matters worse my atmospheric
sensors indicate this planet's environment contains high levels of
poisonous oxygen my life support system can't wait I can die my life support
system can't function for only 30 days if I can't repair the dolphin by then no
I better not think about it I must find the missing ship but can you die in this
game oh yeah over just means is it too loud or you dying 30 days no joke bro
can we zoom out a bit no this is very old technology I'm afraid right let's
investigate are you oh we found something
have you chosen what gen 2 is going to be called instead of gen 1 called and
does all the gents have been named already she knows what they are lol I
sure you think has appeared before me I had barely begun my search when it reared
up as if it were waiting for me it then dropped a single seed what is this it is
alive it is a machine it resembles a vegetable in my home planet that we call
an onion I shall call them an onion too
an onion
oh first little pickling oh my god I'm gonna pull on your stem I'm gonna pull
so hard and I'm gonna yank on your stem the seed that the onion dropped took
root in the soil and has now produced an adorable little sprout this sprout
emits a strange light as it sways back and forth without benefits of wind I
cannot help but think it is calling to me I am compelled I must approach it and
press alpha are you ready I'm gonna I'm gonna touch your stem
oh hi oh my god you're actually kind of cute though
extraordinary when I plucked the sprout it turned out to be a living creature not a
plant picking it has done no visible damage it just stands there staring at
me its shape is similar to the pick pick brand carrot I love so much I believe I
shall call it pickling here I am stranded on a toxic planet fighting to
survive and yet I'm intrigued I must research this fascinating creature I
shall try to grab it and throw it with an a and then I will call it to my side
with B hmm perhaps it will also react to analog stick in X as well fuck there is
no X I wanna yes I'm gonna have to start sparring chips the following controls
appear to allow me to several viewpoints rotate zoom in and out oh thank
god that's what we need I must survive I need to familiarize myself with the
controls of my surrounding right zoom in and out yes right B means come to me X
means menu so what does this do come what do you do that do I don't know what
the flower does right come right I'm throwing you over here at this flower
oh my god that's right spank you baby boy oh my god right so X is hide up so he
sucks and then I got more I get more picklings are you using a game-cube
controller yeah yes yeah astonishing the onion has sewn more seats the small
red pellets the pinkling harvested after cutting down that flower appears to be
some type of food that can proper propagate more picklings the onion seem
to have a sort of incubator needless to say I must study this strange life for
more right pick this up no I keep open in the wrong way no beaming's come to be
why yes okay and then who okay why is to get them oh my god we have three we
have five little babies oh my gosh oh look there's another one we can grab oh
oh my god come here right now I do no wait had to tell him to do something wait
no it's why I'm learning I'm learning okay you like these MLG straight and then
zoom out why did you zoom out I never gave you permission to do that right
everyone go well someone go there no sorry head after all sorry I'm done what
no I keep a I keep opening the menu I'm so sorry can I throw you oh a with a
is a throw that makes perfect sense okay yes go and then go why on that why so
hard on that why all over go no sorry give me a saying give me a saying give me
a saying this is just this is just new technology that don't do okay he's gonna
bring it back and then I'm gonna tell all of them to follow me I mean you could
help him if you want right all of you listen to me why are they unspawning I
need you to all follow me I'm a very special I'm sorry ancient controls are
but we're to get used to why is hold right and everyone stop holding and
everyone come with me everyone come oh my god why is the angle just changed no
this is a terrible there we go I was gonna say that's a terrible angle I can't
deal with that no I didn't and again I just figured I had to change the camera
right there we go right and then whistle 7 right okay and then you're all
getting thrown on to this come and do this thing right there and then that'll
spawn many and we'll just so that's my purse ship oh dear oh dear right okay
once they come over I guess we can move that cardboard box and go to the next
location hydrogen check I'll finish my tea cute little game but yeah I didn't
throw up in the taxi I took my iron supplement I took my auntie sickness
thingy and when I got to the dentist she was really nice and yeah I just passed
I just passed out a fair day we give my rulers we beakers okay so now I can have
12 this is cute oh my god look at you three flan no I'm next to get milked by
mommy no I'm next to get milked by mommy one two two two two two two three
go everyone do we good oh shit I'm sorry sorry I didn't mean to put you on
the box you open the box I came oh look at them helping each other it's such a
good pop glad to hear 11 hours of sleep and no throw up well done on it no no
cavity I wash my key now I see the number one so I have to go back to the the
pinklings are as curious as children they form groups to perform tasks that
would be if possible for an individual a glimmer of hope has begun to shine in my
heart it is if I can make use of their skills perhaps I can fix my ship I shall
sum up all I've learned in the conduct press it approach approaching press a to
pick sprouts press a to grab them and release the throw be a column back to
last why to dismiss you see to command and control the group good luck with that
right everyone follow me okay we're gonna grab these things someone on that one
go take it back
hey why did he say one up there go grab it one two three four five go this is a
tight ship operation we're getting them all right that looks like all oh no not
that can I rotate yes can okay so they're all can you help them to go faster
oh they do speed up oh wow yeah they speed up if you put more on it okay we'll
get these buddies then we will pick up the spaceship and then I think that's
level one time we're still good mommy busting it out with mommy grinned me
into polyamory is so job I know are we it no you know with many Pikmin seeds
at once I find it rather tedious to pluck them from the ground my wife always
told me I was no good at routine tasks I guess I'll try and get it all done by
repeatedly tapping a until I pick them all follow the ground I've noticed that
when I add Pikmin to the group they become filled with excitement and blush
a bright red at other times they revert to a particular pale hue of a dim glow
play paying close attention to these differences is bound to help me
distinguish between Pikmin I'm spamming me I'm spamming me I'm spamming okay
well they weren't the other ones weren't ready yet so I can't spam that much okay
let's spam me spamming I'm spamming me well at least they thought about the
quality of the game when you're like doing all the wee seasons right and then
zoom out again please thank you and we're gonna go get the ship part all
right I need you all working together for what happens next boom boom oh shit
oops they're oh no they're trying to lift it their willow knees are buckling
left with your knees on your back amazing there's no mistaking it my
ship's engine rest before my very eyes by a stroke of pure luck I have already
stumbled upon the most important piece of my damage craft fate has smiled upon
me don't overwork fall asleep for the night so thanks again don't overwork
just for me what the fuck buy yourself something nice with that money don't do
that I don't thank you for the tip but keep your don't overwork for me what
the fuck yes I will have a good stream but you're doing a double shift for the
don't are you joking all reflin be kind to yourself you make me worry about you
don't do double shift don't turn into a gamble reflin either that other
reflin that was like yeah a gambit and I've got your doughnut on money ready
oh my what do you mean you gambit to get doughnut on money ready stop it you're
stressing me out message received getting a setting job no treat ourselves by
treating you know cute stem by the way yeah you want my stem I mean in another
life I used to milk you I used to milk so hard amazing there's no mistaking it
my ship's engine rest before my very eyes by a stroke of pure luck I have
already stumbled way but I've already read that I've already read that I need
20 all good dolphins main engine it was pure luck that I found this piece first
with this I can at least lift off right stop ready ready go army go go army go
go army go let's go oh my god the way noises they make up starting a Ponzi
scheme now no you better not don't do extra work got it robin a bank have you
seen those people on tiktok committing fraud with those checks they put and they
called out money glitch like as if it was gta they deposit a check and before it
clears they take out the cash and then obviously it's like 23,000 in debt or
something and they were calling out money glitches if it was gta and I was like
this is the funniest thing I've ever heard check for it equals infinite money
like I just like him that's why it was referred to infinite money glitch yeah
take to donate plasma no don't fucking get your blood sucked out of you just get
some moolah oh how long is this game
and I've got an inspection I failed my inspection I thought I passed it but
they were they were like we're coming back over and I was like why everything's
fine and they're like no we're coming back over and I'm like okay then I guess
I'll fuck myself and so I don't know how long this game is but I've gotten a
special I'm pretty sure you already answered this but what is your first
console and all handheld game you it was technically the Gameboy Pokemon Ruby
was the first ever game I technically played but if you want to talk about my
dad's then by curiously it was a halo or mech assault on Xbox original if you
want to get technical thank you typical nation for the two and what inspection a
health inspection no they come when you rent an Australia they come and they're
like mmm I'm inspecting the property and taking photos of all your prior private
you know that I said it's eight hours I think we're doing a part to then it's
the I was just really unfortunate time and yeah they come over and they're
like mmm they said it was fine and then I got another fucking email and I was
like I said I sent back always like oh I just had one are you sure like it this
wasn't meant for like another tenant you have that maybe lives nearby or
something and they're like no no it's for you strongy and I'm like okay then
I guess I need cleanup after shit but I don't have a failed it they fucking said
it was fine oh glorious with the help of these picklings I've taken a huge step
back towards home my ship can once again lift off the glimmer of hope is
beginning to burn more brightly but what has become of the remaining parts that
search starts tomorrow I am treating myself so don't worry mama I will keep
doing doubles for my happiness you have much of it already oh husky thank you but
don't overwork yourself it's really you get burned out and you'll feel really
icky inside oh my god my army's leaving me come back here I'm not they go to home
at night wait what happens at night they go in the well got sucked into my ship
I don't think we can go to space at the hall the fuselage hello oh yeah they're
following me the bugs they follow in me mom day one since impact I have something
managed to launch the dolphin but I was surprised to see the onion lift off with
me perhaps the Pikmin cannot survive overnight on the planet surface or have
they merely decided to join me for other reasons either way it seems like they
will help me again tomorrow the dolphin is missing 29 parts if I can't recover
them all I may never return home to my family on planet Hocko Teat Hocko Tat
analysis shows life support systems will only function so you can actually die
how can I repair my dolphin in such a short time a dense forest is visible on
the surface below as it holds the key to my survival I name it the forest of hope
I explore it tomorrow
population today's change in population lost in battle I put them to wars
they go into wars
what are we fighting I thought this was a child's game left behind no we're not
leaving anyone behind what the heck left behind wait there is another part in
that area what is that I volunteered to die for mommy no that may be even more
upset oh no I'm scared what are we fighting oh I saw that 20 seed bomb over
there though oh my gosh so they come with me my dolphin has returned to the
surface along with the Pikmin's onion being alone on this strange planet makes
me somewhat uneasy so I shall call the Pikmin out on the onion all I need to do
is stand in the light beneath the onion and press alpha alpha anyone I'm sorry
right everyone come
oh they're so cute they're just like you right grab that grab that
a yellow oh we get different oh my god there's like actually a tame trial what the fuck the
days are tamed no I'm nervous and I can see a bug or something behind that screen
I'm nervous can you can you beat this up
I don't know if you can beat that up
I don't know hold on this camera angle is really rough
okay hold on let's grab you let's grab you you've just changed the camera angle on my stomach
there's sound potential uh right rotate then it must be this one
I don't know I don't know how many's needed to beat it the fuck up but all of them
that wasn't it hi snowberries we're playing Pikmin today how was did I see two DJs
stream today if I'm not mistaken you guys have got a treat tomorrow
there's a treat tomorrow for you and you're not only I know what the treat is
no you need to be careful you're gonna make yourself sick from working too hard uh I do
apologize to any snowberries that have um played this game before this is the first time I'm playing
it and I'm getting nervous did those bugs eat my babies that little thing there does that
eat my babies can we kill it the DJ stream is on Saturday we were teaching her about sodomy
uh is that when two people bump each other I don't know what that is right I'm nervous
are these things I feel like they're gonna eat my babies oh my god
how did I fucking kill them oh my god how did I kill them can I kill them
does that put does spam them on the one baby don't mommy why did you let me die no
how did I kill them throw a Pikmin at it fuck you bitch
okay oh my god I'll let him die
fucking jump him jump him jump him gang violence gang violence
okay we're gonna harvest all these seeds and we're gonna get the biggest army in all the land
we're gonna harvest them all oh my god we can harvest the bodies of the dead things as well
I like that oh my gosh it's very easy to play this game top down
oh right come on my armies you will grow we will feast on the flesh of our enemies
we will burn them all
oh I can't believe I'll let one die I feel so sad of course it makes sense now that all you had to
fleece feast on the flesh of them
uh clearly the ones being eaten are into blood for the blood of god oh my god they were into
vor all along I can't believe it right let's increase our army size exponentially
let's go come come come come come oh my god this game is so good sorry I'm really liking this game
I like the gang violence that we can participate in as well
okay let's get these what we are 50 almost
46 46
haha 46 pigmen right okay never doing a bit gang violence over here because I saw some stuff here
right he's ready uh beat him up no no no beat him up beat him up beat him up beat him up
make him regret being born okay oh that one looks really big I'm scared of that one behind us
there's a guy I watch who does challenge runs of all sorts uh-huh he did one for this game
and when he realized he wasn't going to make it he built a fortress for his pigmen so they'd carry
on once he was gone that video still makes me a little weepy wait he like you get I can't believe
you can actually die in this game why it's the eternal for you dynamo dynamo I'm sorry I really
love you lots strony you're so heartwarming too bad I can't buy all membership of this only gifted
ones mb bucket my phone's dying victory hand thank you mb buckets please um
haven't your phone died are you outside that you can't charge it you know to charge your phone at work
where are you I'm gonna get you every friend I'm gonna get you out wherever you are
are you in trouble do you need help I'll help you thank you buckets for the super chat and thank
you Oregon as well um I'm scared to like I don't know if I need to look ahead and feel I don't want
to lose I don't want to put you through gameplay where we lose the enemies are going to get bigger
and scarier hi mommy hi me from sorry for being late no don't be sorry you goofy goober right how
much eternal fuse it should light things up for me but how much to open it up like to carry it
40 right get back here right now I've no got 40 on me mate
there seems to be water enemies as well I see stuff in the water over there
okay I need that guy to get off the fuselage
no that's a terrible angle this one
there's definitely stuff in the water
him that bug I don't know if we go to war with that bug
is there something here
yeah I just come back I'm not sure right we have enough to bring the engine part back
so we're just gonna do that for now oh my god look at my babies there's so many of you okay maybe
we can have a gen four you do so cute I don't I don't know if I ever said that I actually really
love having daughters I know it sounds really weird and vicar like obviously because I didn't
fucking birth them but like I feel that responsibility for their success like Mercy just celebrated
like 12,000 subscribers on Twitter and I'm just like oh my god I'm so fucking proud of you like
you're just in so amazing and I'm like so proud of all of them
finally gen four confirmed can we swim I don't know can you guys sneak on to get that one
okay yeah you guys can sneak that's good those big ones are making me nervous though
can we do anything with this it doesn't look like it oh we can my clock has indicated the
coming of noon from now on I must pay close attention to the Sun meter on my monitor and
choose my actions accordingly so it's best for me to review my monitor's data across the top of my
monitor the Sun meter and day display at the bottom of my space put damage meter and Pikmin
gauges from the left these numbers reflect Pikmin under Pikmin in the field and total including
my onions to adjust the monitor I can press a little yes I've been mucking about the camera
water was shallow thank goodness mommy best mother what is this
they're twerking is twerking on it
what how is that not
ah okay we have to like build a pathways oh my gosh okay okay it's starting to click a little bit
a little bit so I'll grab those flowers and I'll grab that engine part
and then what we have to go in the spaceship at night or else they'll die carpenter links carpenter
I'm late to stream how many have been picked I accidentally killed one sadly because I didn't
understand yet fantastic work babies right you grab those for me beat them up beat them up beat
them up that flower is changing floor go grab them and grab that one
I love the noise we're making right we'll grab this engine part and then
that's it hop to three four hop to three four this game is so cute okay I'm starting to understand
why this is a beloved game this is adorable but it's only adorable when they don't die and I don't
know what to do about the big monster uh da tell them to attack this monster
I think I'm gonna have to I don't really want you to fight though
but I think if we want to progress
um uh I'm not sure what to do
large monster throw Pikmin on its back until it dies is that really I don't want to sacrifice my
bubbies I'm getting nervous I guess the best I can do is literally just harvest everything
and then send them off for a fight but it's really not ideal
sorry I'm really struggling with the camera right they're gonna put that on the ship
okay we've got a new part we're gonna go beat up that a bug next
eternal field dynamo dynamo this should light things up no more candles I have never covered
to it there if I can find just three more I should be able to increase my ship's capability okay
uh are we missing
who are we missing someone's missing who what we're winning why
I can't see them it says I've got 78 on the board who are we missing
pinkling pinkling where are you where are you
where is he he's in the corner check the map
by the wall under the ship oh I see him oh my god you guys have better eyeballs than me
can't wake up right uh unfortunately it's war time I don't know how to do this without killing too many but
good luck babies I love you beat them up beat them up beat them up beat them up beat them up
no no no keep going they're one shot and they die it's inevitable to lose some pipe planes
it's a good idea to keep them alive as long as you can the older they get the stronger
Pikmin get so fewer can do more you can tell they're growing because the leaf on their head
butson becomes a flower oh my god does it oh my god I lost seven in that fate that's actually
quite a lot oh my god there's another one right well just knock down this barrier I guess
we are very very good thank you anonymous I didn't know their head can become flower
god these monsters there's one right behind this door as well
should I keep exploring or should I go back
I think I should go back it looks like it's going to be the end of the day like I dilly
dallyed for too long
almost out of date yeah I was gonna let them destroy this wall and then come back to this map
you're supposed to take the big ones from behind was that not from behind
okay I feel like that one's a trap like if I send them to go kill that one we're not gonna make it
right come
right I can kind of investigate this tin a bit more just there is like bits on the floor I don't
know what that means no okay the tin isn't anything it's just details come right let's go back home
and sleep on it can I cross that body of water with them I think so they look like plants so you
know why would they drown that doesn't seem to make anything okay we've got 86 now that's not bad
they will drown how'd I get over there then curious curious curious oh sorry let's zoom out
right everyone go home go home I don't know how to go home okay just like that my clock is indicating
the approach of sunset Pikmin waiting beneath the dolphin and onion will probably enter the
onion on their own but if I don't call the stragglers and add them they won't be able to get back
I am sure that the Pikmin still planted are safe but I am somewhat concerned about leaving Pikmin's
to defend from themselves in the dark right go up all of you go in the ship every single one of you
go beam him up scuddy and then I'm a go and mash it oh look at how cute these are
be mash it you previously attacked the big from the side which still works okay casualties underscore
mama okay okay thank you stash power I think I get um I'm union thank you chair as well uh
right I have recovered two 30 ship parts just three more parts will increase the dolphins
capabilities and repair my space so okay right lit can I go in can I go in no no no can we go in
call it night nope I just stand here and wait until the day's over
they're in the ship they're safe
yeah the Kenton's gonna make me nervous but I'm here
okay I'm learning okay we wait
well we got a new part that's the good thing I guess if we break down this wall here I think
they're strong enough to break down that wall now because I've got literally 86 which is opus work
yeah no stragglers
I'm sure there's like some oh that makes perfect sense
that makes perfect sense why they can't sit down today since impact it appears that many
of the ship's parts have landed in this region if I can just recover the parts of my radar I should
be able to use my radar screen how that would improve my chances that I'd only have to press
why to locate the parts hydration check I'm very dehydrated after that slumber
love me picklings yet dot dot dot there seems to be many hostile life forms if I am attacked and
my space suit takes damage I must return to my ship stand in front of it and press a to make
repairs as I explore must pay attention to my suit's damage meter in the bottom left corner of the
screen oh my god we even have graphs the show the pop no lost in battle a it was me I'm we could
have had 94 oh my babies I've betrayed you you trusted my my I've only got one part in this area
yeah something tells me we're gonna have to go back down in this region because that's rough
we salute the falling falling fall in pickling okay let's break down that stone wall because
there's a 20 seed bomb right there which will increase her a thingy's very much right you
let's bring the whole gang out
bunk hi scrawny hi reflin right we're getting a bit better over the camera angle haveage wait
it repaired the flowers come back I suppose if you completely twat yourself up with it right
everyone on the stone wall I will not take no for an answer beat the living daylights out of that
wall do you understand me keep going don't stop wait there's only so much they can do
wait they can't do it right they can't do it okay I guess right guess we'll go the other way then
right zoom out with this button
oh so if you twat up how many you need you have a chance to get more
not strong enough no they're not no don't be up the wee ones oh the wee ones are what we were
gonna get tomorrow you silly Billy okay let's I'm not gonna throw them all willy nilly if that's the case
oh we have a fight ahead of us then right take those back
yeah okay right I actually like that mechanic if you fuck up too much oh my god one of them has
a flower oh my god we have a veteran on our team easy peasy win easy peasy win we have a veteran
on our team right so this is the problem with this one that fucking things there but that one
that is awake is also there can I go around fuck what are you no no no no no no no no no no no
why did you fucking start attacking I'm so sorry please attack it please attack the fucking
stop attacking the plants oh my god I'm so sorry please attack the thing
oh my god I couldn't have bolster up harder if I tried I couldn't have bolster up harder if I tried
oh my god please right everyone respond oh my gosh why did they do that so they start attacking
the plant that was on the other side a panic my babies only have 77 there's a wall to break
oh my god you just ate gym they actually did though right what's this some part what
are these strong
now hold on a minute
are we introducing colors hold on you guys put that down I'm not sure it's time for you do that yeah
yellow is strong hello hi the color is different but it seems to be a Pikmin
nonetheless first glance it suggests this one has in some circles could be considered very
large ears it looks like it may weigh less than the others in what other way might this be different
no matter they are obviously quite similar so I this was Pikmin as well
they carry the bombs how do I tell this one in particular
remember each Pikmin has their own abilities depends on the color
okay how do I tell that I want the yellow one to do the bombs
I want the yellow one but he's at the back right fuck it everyone's getting sent until the yellow
one comes right come on surely there's definitely a better way to do this but hey oh
come on
right and then bomb that
the glowing rocks in the yellow Pikmin picked up some explosive stones perhaps they know these
stones can be used as powerful weapons the bombs are dangerous so I must take care of using them but
these should be able to blast the stone walls and with blocked pathways okay okay
I must be vigilant just Pikmin I dismiss by pressing X bring their bombs when I call them back
Pikmin I throw wait I can kill
uh now hold on a minute I forgot when I was where did the where did the yellow one go I need it
oh my god did I just softlock myself
am I just softlocked myself
just when I was about to exceed 100 in the field that I knew stopped expelling cg at the number
continued and stored uh did I just softlock myself
oh my god please tell me these are gonna spawn a yellow one
there is no way I just did that come on these are all red
uh wait these are all red
all local
yellow has to carry the I don't know what to do
I don't know what to do
I've never seen a Pikmin play do something like this congrats no wait like what do what do
right can some of you go in the ship right I'll put a few using the ship okay
sure grab that one while you're at it since the seeds right now
uh move to the wall whistle and select the yellow and throw him okay
select the yellow one behind the wall okay let's let's try this again come
uh I don't know what are you at you god there's so many stragglers on the map
I mean hold on can I change the angle are you coming
Danny just he's I can't like glitch him through the wall either
how do I manage that I'm not being funny but how do I manage that I'm feeling personally
attached right now honestly can I like
I've told him to go inside does he like despawn or is he still stuck
he's still there I just saw the top of his head
actually soft logged myself I can't pick up those either
select the yellow I can it's behind a wall what do you mean select them
he can't pick up any more bombs like I'm hovering over him with the the we
he's like there but I can't select them
um
d-pad to change what Pikmin
what whoa I'm getting caught what the fuck
put me down I'm trying to rescue your brethren
you can switch their Pikmin on the d-pad no what the fuck how
uh
I don't know what to do I think I'm gonna have to reset the day and just pray they'll
give me another yellow there is an attempt this is genuinely impressive
I guess I'll just farm for more and then just call it a day put all the
right away yeah gonna gonna heat up don't be don't be shy to help out your
brethren or just ignore me that's fine
you need to restart the day you soft lock brah I can't believe I did that
food for more yellows okay I understand I will I'm just gonna collect to build
are you serious I use the bridge just see it oh my god I have to watch him
drone this game is sick this is a sick sick game what the fuck everyone get in
this goddamn spaceship what a sick you I seem to be getting ones with flower
heads at least so I guess they're stronger for next time we do fight everyone
get away you can call them back in but there's never much hope
get in this goddamn spaceship these are health hazards to yourselves stop doing
the gardening over there get in the spaceship again there are no red on
your team where everyone go again and stop pulling up the grass over there and
right is that everyone or well other than you know who right there's five on
accounted for on the map so let's go find them there's no one hiding behind my
spaceship is stuck behind it let's go I've got a straggler and you go and
what about I've got three more stragglers since the yellow one is what the fuck
are you hello what are you what I do with you all let me guess I throw a fucking
Pikmin on you but I've lost all my Pikmin so I can he do nothing yeah that
sounds about fucking right that sounds about effing right yeah we moat bag yep
that sounds about effing right the one time I don't have a freaking thing right
I'm gonna find the stragglers wherever they are or did anyone get stuck on the
bridge be honest I don't like it so can I swim right so I can swim just to see
what's ahead okay well I can't be ahead that much kind of collect all the
duckling can I pick up bombs wouldn't this game be a lot easier if I could do
the bombing oh you're here that's three of three and then the yellow one that's
still stuck behind here I'm surprised it's just straight up not being attacked
hey come on time to go home we'll wrap up this day we'll call it a dud because
that was a killed a few sacrificed a few so mama you have to restart from the
pause menu oh the days will continue and you will remain soft locked in this area
okay right let's try that again then thank you stash power let's try that again
hmm I would like to visit this planet for the first time
gives us another attempt at the battles to okay the forest I hope more like the
forest the soft lock be elemental parts yeah I'm probably pick me also have
their weaknesses depends on the elemental parts they have lost sorry okay let's
speedrun this so we've got a boss fight if I'm not gonna eff it up this time I
honestly didn't lose too many like not to be like it was a sacrifice I'm willing
to make but we didn't lose too many right they're getting stuck on the door
how about you come over here and then we all fight together huh would you like
that would you like to fight together yes a bit this is making me a third
playthrough of Pikmin for there's four Pikmin right if you guys can you sneak
around no why are you fighting the plant please please stop I never said do
that stop it come around no motherfucker oh my god sorry child's game by the way
I swear if they're getting mold behind me right now because I tried to sneak up
on this fucking thing if they are getting mold behind me I'm gonna cry right
no one's getting mold no one's getting eaten everyone attack go just beat them
up just okay well can I attack them from behind now no keep going no he ate one
you fucking vampire no don't and then don't stop picking them up stop picking
them up I need to kill this we won here right just fucking destroy them annihilating
jumpscare them right there now oh my god right that was so much better right
everyone take the corpses back and harvest them did I make myself here
clear harvest the corpses make them regret being born right you lot you lot
can fuck off as well there's too many years everyone get away go pretend to
destroy that gate it's cuz there's too many and I need access to the yellow one
right everyone fuck off of these I know I want to harvest the yellow one right
tell me what's the yellow one up tell us that the yellow ones all of it was we
big ears stop collecting the yellow furs with a red pigment oh shit oh for
goodness sake right I'll recall them I'll recall them right in what ways like to
be different no no no they matter they matter right I'm not throwing the yellow
one over the damn fence right I'm gonna drop that right now drop what you're
doing drop them right yellow one you're coming with me no no yellow what how'd
that so I can tell when I've selected him is when I'm looking at him oh okay
explosively charged got it okay I didn't realize I could make them run in
circles like that you can separate scholars we stopped doing that a long
time ago right everyone relax and then you come and then you new come but stay
on this side of the frickin bit oh wait so why didn't that not happen first time
I just about new to myself until oblivion right yes the yellow ones can
break stone stuff got it I must be vigilant I do yes okay soft locked again
yellow died I swear to God did he actually
needed oh my god are you how do I how do I do this I literally can't go over the
wall how do I do this to myself restart the level okay third time's a motherfucking
charm third time's the charm you need to use yellow to grab more pellets make
more yellow okay I'm okay I'm starting to come to consist yeah okay oh okay I'm
gonna create more yellow yes I agree we're gonna create more yellow through
the whole button hold the throw button and use the pad to select I'm literally
never been more successful in self-locking myself in my life right you
don't need a Camden you don't need to just just take a moment and Camden
right how you come right no one gets stuck on the wall randomly okay come
come come come come come come there we go right I've got my army you and whose
army did I tell you that time my grand threat in the mafia right and we're
gonna jump them oh the flower one can keep up he's got like speed right don't
know I'm not telling you to do that so don't right beat him up then but didn't
wake up the other one didn't wake up the other one didn't wake up the other one
didn't wake up the other one do you understand you can prompt
okay one singular seat but first I will send I will send my army to spank him
in the back go beat him up plays arse like the drums you can bang the drums
ah ah ah no one died wait how are they dying at him from behind okay harvest
right everyone everyone everyone shut the fuck up okay everyone you shut the
fuck up as well thank you up how is there still red with me pretend it's
mommy's babe never played pikeman bed I played overlord which is similar but all
of Mars some stragglers came up to join last second literally I just want the
yellow in okay I won a Scottish Chinese cuz where's the yellow shite alright no
no no go to sleep everyone go to sleep you go make more yes yes right and then
you listen to me yes oh my god we're doing it it only took me a third turn
right it only took me a third try okay you listen to me and go again and then
you come and come the other one's ready to harvest yeah I don't know but we're
doing it oh my god we have loads of bomb ones we have tons of bombs that's all I
need la bomba okay okay okay and then we grow you there we go we're oh gorgeous
stunning 10 out of 10 I'm sure this mechanic is not gonna upset me at all
later date the yellow ones are cute she don't want it anymore I think so please
don't please don't randomly just stay up there right what did I do last time
right one at a time you're getting sacrificed okay no just one I just need
one okay that'll do that'll do right can right grab the bombs pick them up no
just ignore them it's fine I didn't want bombs anyway can you maybe just do it
from a distant right go grab a bomb good yes you've shown me this three times
now I understand the mechanic thank you for explaining it for a third time mmm
no more no more soft lock in though okay I've had enough I'm no funny right the
one with the bomb go and then everyone back off
aha the bomb rocks are dangerous so I must take care when using them okay I
think we did it I think we did it I must be vigilant yes yes we will be
vigilant we will be vigilant we promise we promise we promise us to be good we
do oh my god we did it it only took how long right go and then go get him okay
we did it everyone it's time to attack okay and we've got a good mix right he is
ready fuck him up oh yeah attack attack attack oh my goodness there's like
rubbery things in the ground please attack please attack I'm begging you
we just got jumped right what are you up there there's something up here right
go grab it and send it home that'll do take those send them home pick up that
grub send it home make it regret being born it's my whimsical radar with this
I'll be able to see all nearby ship parts and with just a glance by person why
nope oopsies whoa whoa where you take oh my god I thought I was take them over there I was like
ah there's more grubberies fucking shag them oh my god we're getting jumped be a mom oh what the
fuck I'm actually gonna die in this game I'm not being funny okay we can at least replenish our
number what is going on I'm about to die Lamal I'm about to die I'm actually about to die in
game oh my god my wee babies are dying too oh my god go kill it bro this game is hard I thought
it was supposed to be like nice smooth relaxing me oh my god I'm dying I can't make it right two
of you why not help that one because there should be two years right we've got a few more yellows
which I'll take I'll happily take some yellows because we've got some needs for bombs now
right use listen stop looking listen a can I get one of you to make more bombs
okay give me that okay close enough yes and then the one with the bomb
cycle through them no no no no don't lift me up
I can't I can't pick another one oh shit they made it okay that's good that's good
okay we've got another part and I sent you both discord alternate versions and stream over
the aspect ratio
whatever you say
monkey oh it like actually looks professional hold on is it that hold on wait hold on a minute
hold on a minute
wait was that wait
I like I have so much I have so much real estate over here oh I forgot I took off all
the reflins with that one I thought I have so much real estate oh my god professional streamer by the
way most kid games were hard as hell for no reason I know I've never covered three out of 30
part bro we're dying I'm just saying that right now we are not getting off this planet right who's
the one with a bomb you bomb I have made yet another Pikmin related discovery just when I was
about to exceed a yeah okay okay okay wrap it up wrap it up you always manage to play games on
legendary difficulty or doing it right one with a bomb yes you know right everyone go to sleep
and then you with a bomb bomb go then everyone back off
okay I'm getting it I'm getting it you just had to right and then
just take that one home
yeah that's fine and then you bomb
and then you bomb
send it over I know you guys say I can pick between the Pikmin I haven't seem to have
clicked the button that lets me rotate between them no I keep going on the right there bomb
okay one with a bomb you first go and then run away okay then you with a bomb we're gonna open
up the other one as well we're doing it we're doing it we're doing it we're doing it we're doing it
we're doing it bombo one you need to destroy this
yes the bomb bomb no not you come back and then sleep and then the one with the bomb
fucking hell this is taking me away oh get back get back get back get back there's this is this is a
C4 quarry no that's not far enough or is it gonna know what to do
how long am I gonna take to do that uh 20 minutes
I just have I'm supposed to do that one
I don't know I've now have two bombs I don't know if that's enough to do anything with
one with the bomb please
this is it I have to keep bruh it's hardly moving
this one just takes a lot of bombs okay did the bombs replenish daily I think I'm already out of
bombs from that tin oh I need a bit more of an army I think even who's on me
come
bruh this game is unironically really hard
I can't even figure this shit out are you joking oh my god look at my red army in the background
I'm not sure
how do this right you just come with me just in case we get jumped by something I would like
some on hand right there was more bombs back here in this tin so I guess I'll just get them to grab
a ton of bombs and I'm just gonna assume they replenish
the bombs inside the tin you know that really obvious thing that you're supposed to do
can you do that that would be grand the bomb inside the tin thank you jeez oney has got it
all right so I'm gonna fart I'm angry nine total I think
you seem cute yeah that's because aren't women the cutest when they're almost
sometimes right okay bomb time surely this will be enough bombs
okay there we go no bomb right can you split into two yes oh my god this is exactly what I need
come I didn't really tell them why would do that
almost done surely copy them oh come on
I don't have any more bombs
and I'm out of time for this day right everyone getting the spaceship I'm not having anyone
dying because of masturbity any of the spaceship in go
everyone's going in there that's fine now to put the red to bed
put the red to bed there's more bombs ahead and oh with those monsters okay all right
you little space gathering you in bedtime go you too it's your bedtime as well I'm not risking it
I'm not risking it okay I'm never gonna pop all these
why is there a yellow one with me
where did all these yellow ones come from
mommy trying to save as well I made progress that's the mean thing I definitely made progress
controversial but this game is really hard
okay I'm not even gonna bother spawning in a new one I probably should like I shouldn't be lazy like
that but uh maybe I can tell these yellow ones to take these away I assume even though it's a red
button it doesn't make a difference or does it what does he do anything dangerous I hope not
well if he doesn't do anything dangerous I'm gonna leave him be then
right quickly quickly no
I don't really have time for years to be playing at this dangerous
come on quicker quicker quicker two years two years on one
two years on one there you go nice and fast nice and fast look at your speedy gonzalez's
yeah he's a super fan a buzzing bun thank you for becoming a member please enjoy the emotes
I'm sorry about the pregnancy actually I need to get an update on AC, Maryssey and Emmys and
the emotes oh don't fucking say that to me you're gonna stress me out
I think they said if it was in the ground they're fine I think if they're in the ground they're fine
so I'm gonna just let them do their thing and then I'm gonna run back to the spaceship
they got zoomies as long as you're on pace you're golden is it just I need one new item a day and
then I'll be fine everyone other than the seedlings are Pikmin in the ground are safe and will grow
stronger damn okay advantageous right we didn't lose anyone sorry I don't know why my tongue was
out there I was not talking with my tongue I promise hi Jason check
technically one item a day okay I'll take it one item a day that's the objective
only took me how many tries at day three to get that far
wink wink nine thousand thank you I don't think I said thank you I'm getting really bad for that
honestly all right we're complete at day three and it only took me one hour an hour and an hour
an hour and a half to get to day three come on me wonder I never complete this is a kid so
like I got stuck on the first level okay we've been beamed up
first try egg sec we got that spaceship is a mess
oh they're so sweet I really don't like those things
day three three days since impact I now added yellow Pikmin to my list of discoveries these
creatures can wield bomb rockets so perhaps I can use them to blast down rock walls and open up new
regions red and yellow Pikmin as well as bomb carriers break into small it's so cute with that
little sprout on your head I do you like it it's like an anime you know how like anime always
have like a little piling powing at the top of their head I grabbed one a for the moment thank
you uh alli vivas for the tip and yeah no like look it sat so well I've never made one sit so well
before and population
oh it doesn't go higher than the bubbles even though it's like way higher
these remaining parts remaining okay we finally made it to day four get round of applause for day
four everybody day four I can't wait to play uh some dragon quests and also the stories guys
because this oh there's a third space for the for another claw I assume blue on the basis of
everything right my army out you come let's do like 40 years what about my yellow army tell me how
you really feel I've got 20 years not as strong but we're gonna blow this shit up okay first things
first let's yeah let's blow up the area look they all have flowers right yellow did I make myself
clear no red go away separate yellow one two three pick up the damn bombs pick up the bombs are in
front of you okay and then come and we're gonna blow up this really easy door that's right here
come come come come come okay a tune hope separate I want bomb links this way newt clings if you
will that's what I want to see baby one one bomb ah ah two bomb ah ah three bomb ah ah
okay we're unlocked a new area bombing are you guys strong enough with it I'm just good
um I get I'm gonna bring up back up you know uh why not use so that one of them has a bomb and I
want them to put it down I'm getting a bit scared of them to be honest okay right you pop that in there
I'll also try and grab that other part too I'll grab use I know these are the wrong color but
I'll take this anyway and then we can just separate use when they're not ready
buzz and buzz thank you for the 10 gifted memberships as well what the heck I get to
pop your cherry and gifted as well thank you that's very generous congrats to those who caught it
with your face please pick up the bombs bomba bomba
okay lovely you love to see it come we might have a fight ahead so I'm just gonna make sure
I'm starting to understand how a lot of them can become strays now like a lot of them can become
strays right bomblings I'm gonna need you to do your thing bomb okay close enough close enough
right separate a bit more and then bomblings gorgeous stunning kind of and then bomblings
surely four will do it surely four will do it and then we can get this new part
come on
everyone claim a board right how many do we need we have 57 apparently in our arsenal so off you pop
and we only need 30 for that part gorgeous stunning 10 out of 10 we've got we're on par
there we go I think I would like to have an army before I go into this next section
bombling I would like you to put down that bomb thank you
he had enough he had enough he said nah I'm out
it's the extraordinary bolt I bought this incredible bolt because the salesman told me
it was extraordinary quality that is indiscernible to the average person exactly what makes it
extraordinary is the secret uh do you just want to rethink your approach why are you going
through the enemy stop going for the plans right we must sneak beat them up come on you've
got flowers come on you've got flowers oh my god they look so dead when they're on the floor like
that come on baby gorgeous now beat him up make him a grippy and born
yes yes okay now what oh we did a 360 okay right take that as your your airnings your scraps take
him home take him to okay off you go and then I need oh no I need 30s obvious hold on come back
come back come back I need 30 to do this transmitter thing you mobile bar one two three four five six
seven nine ten one two three four five six seven eight twenty twenty one two two three four five
two three four five six six cool enough he got tired of working overtime he's like now you can't
pay me enough for this okay there we go they're moving it that's all I'd like to see and then yellow
wings you guys can clean this one oh I guess not or clean that one too
there everyone work on getting that back I have I have the plait flings these ones are just where
you manually plop them off you go plait plait plait you guys just work on that wall I'm going to go
over here oh 20 bomb can I throw them up there actually I'm gonna heal in front of my rocket
ship I don't think I'm well I have recovered no wait I said heal then I heal me I don't know
oh look at you go he did it we got another part plait plait plait plait plait plait plait
you can probably throw the yellow ones up there yes that is exactly what I'm gonna do
the built extraordinary I have never covered four out of thirty parts just one more and I should
be able to increase my ship's capabilities I don't know what that means oh they're all
celebrating they're so cute right let's get rid of take these guys out
oh so many seedlings oh you're so cute right 20 right 20 I've got 20
can I get used to jump for him like this I don't know what that baby baby baby
okay there we go no way we're about to have a massive ass army oh no the red can't get out
oh no it doesn't we got it we got it oh careful careful careful lift with your knees not with
your back you're gonna hurt yourselves you are you're gonna hurt yourselves you need to be careful
can you be careful oh if I touch them they become mine again
oh they're helping oh my precious little helpers this is cute oh my god
god I'm like collecting these guys like pokemon cards oh my pokemon binder arrived by the way
that I'm definitely doing a pokemon hand cam thing streaming my bulb or thing you guys beat
the absolute shit out of this for me that's great did that even come down a nodgel
what is ringing like a bell
they're on top of it
oh that's far away is that getting knocked down
but yeah I got a polybook so what we're gonna do we're gonna open up a card pack and then I'm
gonna put it away in the polka deck so there'll be a longer hand cam stream hopefully doesn't
put anyone off I'll put my fake nails on okay I'll put my fake nails on because I'm such a girl
by the way I'm a girl I'm a real girl by the way I play games for male attention that's how you
know I'm a real gamer hi Jason check we shouldn't joke because you know what's gonna happen
someone's gonna believe it like that one time I said that joking the person did believe it
shoni's a girl fake nails yeah I can't have like I can't have my nails longer I don't like it
will you be able to open them properly with the nails on yes I can still do everything with the
nails the only thing I can't do is WASD with the fake the like I used to get my nails actually
done the nails salon with my Vietnamese auntie that fucking yanked my toe give it back you bitch
um I used to like get them actually done it's called acrylic nails um and I love getting them
but oh my god she was so mean to me when I said I wanted them short she was like
honey what's the point and I'm like eh I'm a gamer that look like do I look like I'd be
you know away from the water darlings oh there's something ahead right okay these two are these
are in cahoots okay guys these are in cahoots so come around come around that little come oh my god
we're gonna take casualties I'm sorry we're we're gonna have to take casualties all right jump him
first and if it wakes up the other guy that's on me no stop going for the fucking flowers go for
the big ass no no no he's shaking him off he's shaking it up shake it up did anyone die
no oh the he tanked it he tanked it oh no no no I did lose them oh is this gonna be
I can't uh he died okay that's good that's good come right there's a break there's bombs here for
some reason right I don't know how many you need to carry this but carry the fuck over I've cleared
the I have found the nova blaster this emits a dazzling burst of light capture capable of
destroying almost anything I'm not exactly sure about this but the promotional brochure claims that
it blasts can travel in this torrents of time and space smashing through stars okay they got eaten
I think I lost three I'm not sure so there's a bomb spawn here as well for when I need to
explore other areas of the map okay right let's get more picklings in
no not that one but sure you can take it it's fine you need three to carry that one
need ten to carry this one this game is quite satisfying when it comes to numbers it's like
yes yes I do have enough now hold on a minute hold on a minute do that one that one
and that one and then there we carry everything avoid the water though we need waterlings for that
oh there's a hole can I go in it oh it's a shark okay that makes more sense
that makes more sense that makes much more sense
it's just like a shortcut if you want to oh we did it we got two parts in one day
the seasick can use to attack them all at one I know what the seasick stick is
this is a weapon it has a strange allure like the hit feature bird generation want to be a word
indulge thank you thank you no I I know it pleases me increasing the dolphins capabilities my secret
and my search can now cover a wider area
well we're starting to look a bit more like a ship we're still a bit banged up though that's the only
problem it's just a wee bit banged up just a wee bit though veal or reference real
okay right now we need to go backtrack and make sure there's no
links that are left behind oh my god you you're exactly why I'm back here you little
you little thing you you little sheriff right since these guys are fully maxed out I'm actually
gonna pick them out oh my god we have 200 reeflings the army grows okay we're gonna take
bomb link you can come with us drop that motherfucking bomb though do not come to me with that bomb
do you understand right let's check we're gonna put them all away I don't I'd rather make sure
everyone doesn't get left behind we're gonna go back that other way right everyone home
no there's only eight of years out lies everyone go home right now everyone in that ship
I have so many
did they all just come out of that ship no go in the ship
and then you all get inside don't you you left one at the shortcut I'll need to go back from
right who is walking with me red go go it's okay I'm gonna leave them if they're in the
ground because I know they're safe but
the shortcut shortcut there
I'm literally just spamming this any is here
no right no one's here that's good and then I'll do one more swipe around and then the rest might
be in the ground I'm trying I don't see him if he's around I'm coming for you inclin
our reeflings are oh I see you come get in the spaceship what are you playing at
you could have died out here you had me worried sick
right 27 doesn't seem right 27 seems like a really high number
I don't know have I left anyone has anyone been stuck on wall
I'm praying no one got stuck on a wall am I gonna die oh am I gonna die if I'm over here
I saw the shiny thing and I got lost literally
it says 26 Pikmin but there's none on the map
don't don't I'm actually they're in the ground you'll be fine if I'm left out
I'm running get to your ship oh my god you're stressing me child's game by the way
okay hopefully I don't lose any it says 26 on the ground is that what it says on the ground
oh is it like one last call and then whoever gets left behind gets left behind
oh that's rough that's mean that's cruel I guess because they don't have brains
have a lot more in common with the pink things than I thought
okay we're gonna go like top left now
day four since impact with the it's newly increased the dolphin now lifts higher into the planet's
atmosphere I see a great depression in the woods beneath me it looks like a belly button in the
vast forest now that is my ship is more stable I should be able to set it down there is that where
we unlock a lost in bat all right but I never left any behind let them know nothing got right I
assume the blue ones are on this next location and then we come back to previous maps right
we come back to previous maps oh my god why does this look so scary though the forest navel
hydration check no man left behind exactly
exactly hold on I'm just gonna check I think Shivi doesn't feel well so she can see and she's not
feeling very well today when is emmer's getting on I I promise I want to stream more I'm actually
getting a bit nervous about my inspection because I'm like um what do you want from me
those are boss battles in this game oh there are but there's boss but
with what my army of tiny little adorable squishies
is there a boss battle in this level
never leave any behind otherwise it will show them running away like the big one from the big
ones because you can take off and get eaten that is so sad whoever whoever made this game you've
got you're sick you're twisted in the mind why would you show us that thank you stash power
why would they show us that that's so cruel oh by the way you failed in gathering the the little
guys you will now watch them they'll perish they'll suffer they'll be in a lot what
love is going to cry this kid's going to throw right I'm just going in this I assume this is
where the blue ones are so we're going to go get it we're going to get to it the forest
Neva I love this game so much that I hate or cry for anyone who dies my poor little things right
we're in a new area what does analize I see a rock wall for them to beat down I see a
blow-up wall for the yellows I see a bridge to create all right babies rise and shine
right I'm gonna take out like all that I can because I'm nervous about the fights I feel
like we're going to be doing loads of fights right first things first let's break down this wall
go go go go go beat it up beat it up gorgeous stunning 10 at 10 effort this is a water map
if I've ever seen one where is that log that I can break the only log I'd be breaking is on
why are you fighting grass leave the grass alone right that's a bomb that's a bomb as well
god some of yous are aggressive what are you fighting right I guess this is the only way
we can go right now so sure keep attacking what's behind it there's a flower
what about dumb question has the studio done log where the landlord can evict you for
personal use I'm yeah like so um there is a law against landlords doing that in like most countries
they can still do it they still do it they'll they'll be like oh uh I need it for family members
something like that they they'll still do it it doesn't matter they'll go around the law I assure you
landlords do not need permission in the way you think they do
um what is that there's something there's something blue on the ground what is that on the ground
come on beat it up faster faster faster we're like we've already lost like one fifth at 10th of the day
the the poor guitar sounds so tired thank you darlin that was very good for it right what is this
get it oh my god they're digging
what is it wait what's going on whoa stop destroying the plants another intriguing
discovery a local variety of grass produces a yellow nectar when the pink bin drinks this delicacy
instantly matures into and their flower this apparent pink bin favorite seems to be full of
nutrition closer observation needed oh my god you're so strong I love it right can we come down here
we can there's a lot of blue abadi abadi and blue abadi abadi stop destroying the flowers
they're not harvestable yet what's the you're pulling on it okay that's right keep tugging
sorry that was really on the nose that wasn't even oh I see him is he going for me
is he going for me me flanks prepare for war
does he care does he not care oh my god am i being a meanie
are you chill oh my god i'm sorry right everyone disengage disengage right what did i do here what
do you need oh you need like one more shit hold on hold on i'll get you i'll get you up that stick
don't worry okay there's one in the water over there this is definitely a water map of that
can you make it up the thing you can gorgeous but how do you I can see like the silvery no no no
I accidentally just took some off of that freaking thing sorry right let me let me what is the tingling
me now assume it just means check your time right go move that right so we need to bomb that in
order to go forward I need just to make this bridge for us to progress there's a lot of blue
glowy things in the top right corner I don't know if you can see that
make that bridge
oh geez
gosh you guys could have been eaten you know that right
instead those silver ones don't look friendly though
come on keep going i'm gonna just pale you all up on it
come on keep going yes
that was a rock those bugs look like a freaking zone and a half though I'm not sure how strong I feel
oh are they going around did you make it across okay we've got another ship part we've not lost
anyone yet so that's a good news bell times every half quarter of the day okay thank you darlings
next we're not gonna make that bridge just
oh it doesn't matter does it oh my god they look so dangerous
they look so so dangerous I mean I guess we'll unlock the bridge next
because
if we unlock the bridge next it means we can get I assume we're gonna lift an item up for that way
we still don't have access to bombs I see an item there oh I see that massive fucking boss over there
get out flame throwers be warned how do I just have to go behind them I'm screwed empathy is run
dry I'm a three and a good minute I don't breathe I just say what I've never covered six out 30 parts
if I can find six more I should be able to increase my ship's capability so what a new location on
what oh my gosh how do we kill these grubble wobble bugs
there's so many I feel like my babies are gonna get ganged up on can I kill them
Danny bombs to kill the silver things because I'm getting ready to be
right this is a bit of a moment the reds are fireproof segregation time
I really should not say that so the reds are fireproof so fuck them up
okay
oh I'm not fireproof though I'm not fireproof
no come on he's almost down oh my god they're losing their petals like they're losing their
health did anyone die there no only that dude
what sorry I'm trying to like navigate success no leave the grass darlings oh there's nectar okay
get the grass get the grass that's why they're fucking the grass up there's a chance for nectar
to spawn if they pull it off okay halfway through the day okay right fuck them up fuck them up fuck
them up oh my god something's making a noise what's making a noise oh it's just like grub things
my babies are dying oh no no no no oh my god my babies are dying don't just let it fucking
cock stomp you what the fuck no reflings babies don't just let it win
why are you so confused you need to attack what's the problem you need to attack keep attacking
darlings no I'm making it so much worse my instructions are making this so much this is
slaughter it's a fucking slaughter oh my god this is why they say commanders are sheep
fucking commanding lions in a battle because what the fuck oh my god please just destroy it please
I'm trying so hard oh my god it's still not dead oh my god
oh that was terrible that was some bad right go replenish your numbers I've killed so many
of your allies due to my stupidity I need seven
okay they can whisper and then you take that one oh sorry I didn't mean that one
oh my god I killed so many I'll gladly die for mommy no you sound like cannon fodder
oh no sorry I didn't mean that one for you another one just died bro replenish your numbers
no
the grubs are attacking I don't know what to do don't flamethrower me right sorry yellows
you're going back in the spaceship because of the way user carrying on user not very strong
in this area oh unless you want nectar fine did you find nectar it's like taking a dog for a
walk and it starts p is smelling all the pee on the side and like come on there take it take the
nectar off you go oh you're so strong right come on come on I don't want to leave you behind
don't get distracted wow all right I'm taking all red out you mean it's all red always has been
actually you know what might as well just fucking do it get our numbers back I'm so
nervous that feels so bad
oh they're getting nectar
I don't want to leave any on the map either
should be maybe be giving it to the other yinz
oh my god there's so many left behind
they're like stuck on the different bits oh my god not you're making me nervous you're
making me nervous I'm gonna end up leaving some behind so that's all the progress we're making
today I'm not even kidding everyone go home I'm so nervous I'm gonna leave some behind
please go home please go home everyone home now
I'm gonna let the other ones be in overnight just so
stressful management game more stressful I'm gonna leave the other ones to mature overnight
oh you're so mature for your age I'm gonna get that bit of nectar get it get it did you get it
no okay right go home then
right let's take you all home I think if they're near the spaceship as well they don't get
thinking you should probably go grab the blue onion I don't know where the blue onion is
is it on this map
you've got your space pieces so you can pack up early if you want
I'm just gonna check it is nearby blue I need to go through the water
I'm just gonna check those stragglers because they're getting caught on the map
well can you be that young
you walked near it earlier what are you be come here come come on
you just saw it I saw it right let me put these babies away hold on babies need to go bed first
the babies need to go bed
come on come on
bed now I'm not having any stragglers because these are getting caught on things
bed right and then I'm gonna take a shortcut and go this way
something blue you just saw it I just saw it this blue area
oh I thought that was a par and I needed the blue onions to unlock it
okay we have a seedling I'm gonna pluck it and I'm gonna get it to get these ones in the immediate
vicinity okay we're doing it can you tell us a bedtime story once upon a time there was
the story of a brave little reefling this is more like a drumming honestly because you can't
drum this is a pigment of yet another color near this one's cheeks what all face cheeks is what
appears to be a set of girls this trait suggests to me that it can the blue type of pigment can
enter without any trouble there's only one way to find out oh my gosh I got nervous there yeah
go for the flower yeah that's what you're supposed to do the flower I'm so sorry I was like excuse me
right and then go pick that up
I was like aren't these things a bit too cute and adorable to be mucking about with cheeks
right if I leave these guys in the ground it'll be fine right
right you you go up in your spaceship I'm gonna leave the others in the ground to mature well
you're so mature for your age um and then I'm gonna go back to my spaceship and we officially
unlock the white the water blue ones the scissors 29 on the hood get in the fucking stop eating nectar
on your time off making me nervous yes it's fine go to bed eating nectar on your tech I can't believe
it you don't think I pay you enough actually I don't pay you at all check the map if there's any
left behind had I even checked them out no there's none left behind don't do that to me that's the
seedlings okay that's the seedlings I feel like I need to install a mod that just gives you infinite
time there's a red where a red one no I'm about to leave one behind no where I didn't see it
oh no do we need to watch it die
no surely not copy them absolute copy them they're not gonna make me watch one singular red one die
right oh no we get away in the safety of our nest
no no baby no no you got flung like a fucking pancake
deep in the forest cave I discovered blue pics and these yellow these blue fellows have something
resembling gills on their cheeks they appear to be amphibious surviving both in water and land
the wonders of nature never ceases to stun me even in this alien land oh I'm distraught I can't believe
we've lost in battle 18 I had to watch his little body get smushed by a frog
that's so mean I know the game guys probably are trying to encourage you not to thingy so now
that we have blue unlocked will we get all the parts in this area is my question
I think so
it died being sat on it's what it would have wanted yes you can get everything
ah don't cry for my mommy I was a willing sacrifice no my poor baby
uh hey there's hope I'm not late and how well did you sleep I got 11 hours of sleep which means
I did nothing behind the scenes oh yeah okay we're gonna take out the blue
oh no the other ones are germinating on the planet
no the bugs respond are are you serious they fucking respond
oh balls this up
everything respond I don't have enough blue
are you squidding me right now stuff responds when you swap the map are you I'm being squiddled
I've been played for a damn squiddle fiddle you know that right go attack do not kill the blue one
what we do assume if the blue one's the first one to pick up the corpse of this he'll go make
oh my god one died are you joking right blue no no no no no no no that's for blue don't be selfish
no stop
stop right segregation blue blue take that and make more blue okay
quickly quickly quickly I'm so bad
mother it's so cold down here I am no you have taken all my brothers to the safety of the sky
no that's so sad do you hate me no I am sorry I am no longer worthy mother
don't that's actually so sad I'm going to like be crying myself to sleep tonight don't roleplay as
the dead left behind Pikmin that's so sad thank you for the the typhon on my but what the fuck
are you trying to make me upset
uh so if I no no no no you're doing it again I never said do that I said the blue one I want the
blue one give me the blue one so if I put a blue one on it first they're gonna take it to the blue
one right no I've just paused out segregation blue you too grab that one and then that one
and then they'll take it to the blue one because there's more than enough the grumbles are
deep they're grumble fire in the bridge
bro they did not make this easy right sacrifice links go
we've got more than enough yellows okay and then I'm gonna get the blue ones to pick up the bodies
of everything rub lings knock it off
beat them up beat them up oh my god one of them died right I was kind of joking about being
sacrifice links right and then go open up that bridge again again right no no god I suck at this
case so badly right give me the blue yes yes yes yes this is what I want to see this is what I
want to see I want more blues all the blues all the blues okay we're gonna take on a little adventure
with the blues I think there's enough now to do an adventure with blues is there five five or no
six or no I don't know if it's enough
I don't know what's what's over here first let's analyze what's over here we'll go up the tree
spout up the tree yep what's over here
okay sure I'll let yous eat that why not that sounds like popcorn so there's bombs down there
there's a fight here and there's a part here okay
no no nothing okay there you go you gotta be blodge of it increase blues number agreed I'm gonna
make these ones strong as well please have the nectar that only one of them got it right let's
go get more blues come on come on come on come on come on no well does it not
right let's get more much more blues take the grubble take that one
okay more blues more blues
our blood is in your hands mommy no
little tip the blue Pikmin save any Pikmin that are drowning oh that's nice I'm glad
okay but one more we're needing like we need like 20 to be able to take on that monster I don't
even know how many we'll need to take on the parts of the other thing as well
a lot of yellows around here oh sorry no no no no not that one no I want the blue
actually taking the liquid over there sure sure you can do that I'll forgive you
okay how many is this 15 is that enough to take on a bug
15 to take on that big old bug uh I need to be able to lift that thing as well
go forth and multiply breed breed my little bluelings breed
all right is there any more grubbles nope
okay oh this flower is ready to bloom
yeah I would say I can see how this game got so popular it's very cute and adorable
it's a bit pernickety for me but that's just how it is like that's how games are
like they can't even make it super easy or else you know you wouldn't have the motivation to play it
but like going kind of back and forth a little bit with the claws who's your claws any claws
I'm already like tingling in through halfway through the day and like oh no no no keep them out keep
them out okay but we're doing it though that's the main thing right I think we'll have enough to
now do that item but over the water
come on you can do it come on how many have I got for Cephirum
no not the yellow one go wait they are much better
are these yellow or are you blue I've been pranked they were yellow all along
right that's more than enough to deal with that monster come on then come on then 20
three of us no just see him right 23 and one's a flower no as tempted as I am for your right can
everyone make it up here or no you're all stuck right come this side of the log then
can you make it sounds like it kind of a little bit stuck they're coming come on
you can do it a little bit over a little bit over yes come on come on I don't want to put
you in a fight that you're not gonna make it how many to move this
fuck I don't have 30
it's the shock absorber the apparatus that the shaking and swing that normally occurs in flight
still I don't have enough I don't really want to send them to a fight either but
I think I have to
oh my god they're so weak
they're so weak oh my god I'm about to deplete my fucking
oh my god oh my oh no come back come back come back come back come back come back I'm sorry
I take it back I take it back oh my god they're so weak
bro is this entire day just going to be for breeding them I think so and I want to go
oh I can't believe I did that just killed them all I'm gonna fucking deplete it right at least
you can use your strong enough to beat this one oh no oh my god how could I have messed this up so
much
I can't believe that are you serious how could I have messed that up so freaking terribly
it's a and I think I genuinely think this is just a straight-up breeding day
and I'm needing to breed them they're beggining for a pigglin I'm needing to breed them
all right you can grab that grab that's in the water because you're blue
yes take it and you take one of these oh my god they won't I am make reeflings not war I'm
literally I don't know what's happening all of a sudden they're just dropping like flies
right I can take them across the water oh my god do those fish attack you be honest
do those fish attack right come up here and deal with that flower at least
oh my god I already it's already finished the day
right you and then next time I come down I'll get them to destroy that bridge and then we can
pick that item up and then we'll go fight the other ones as well right and I'll tell the yellow
ones to come follow me reefling breed via peggy no no no no no no no yeah I promise I promise
you always want to greatly outnumber the enemy to the lose the least amount yes
I'm surrounded right that looks like a lot more though like a hell of a lot more
blues I need 30 blues
copium
right can everyone go to bed if they if I'm near the spaceship they'll all go
in right I don't have to manually tell them so many bodies the blood over blood so many brothers
no let this happen mommy's not a good commander this is why I fight on the battlefield with you
not without you I'm too rubbish I'm literally too rubbish thank you the bill or thank you
Florian Hainesville as well for becoming a member right I'm going to leave them in them
ground to Germany uh no I'm not gonna grab this one really quick because I didn't realize there was
a flower here play that thing like the maracas right and then we'll put you away and then we're
gonna check my map which I do by pressing that okay item item item oh my god and there's an item
behind that fight that didn't do right okay and there is an item down there that I didn't do is it
a bombable wall okay tomorrow we will pick up the blue things that one and that one there we
can pick up because we have enough you got confused where are you taking it yeah take it to the blue
one did they die did they die if you don't pluck them
right where they die if you don't pluck them the bluelings have been dead for me if they honestly
have oh at random it assigns them
okay okay right in the spaceship then you know so it's out 16 12345678910
still need more the entire day of breeding wasn't enough okay let's wrap it up let's wrap it up I
have recovered oh did I get attacked now you don't think so mummy refused a request for a
resupply and repo reinforced but I'm trying I'm trying to breed the absolute living daylights out
yeah this is hard this is very hard oh we yawn hold on I didn't realize how much I was kind of
covering up my my hair so bad oh god I'm covering up the newest member and latest tipper as well I'm
so so what an unprofessional stream honestly put me in the bin um I'm gonna work on ic's ASMR video
because hers is got is easier to make so it's not very easy to have an update I promise I didn't
know I was gonna pass out for 11 hours okay so do forgive me on that part but not enough breeding
mume getting bred by mummy for a whole day literally that's how I'm like plop plop plop give me more
give me blue give me blue are you like what the fuck I don't control the color it comes out and I'm
like just do it just do it okay we'll come back down to this planet no one's gonna be eaten by the
meanie the weenies because they were so stinky I mean
I have a membership ASMR today oh shit
I'm gonna have to do that now whoops right we'll play one more day and then I'm gonna wrap it up
in a nice pretty bowl I forgot I had ASMR because I was so distracted by the instruction whoops
see no one died because I'm a good mummy promise right we'll do one more we'll do one more day
we're gonna grab those two two thingamabobbers uh in the flower at night that's cute I have seen
that at the leaf atop of Pikmin's head will grow into a bud and then flower appears that if they do
not pick the specimens sprouts they gradually bloom overnight fantastic okay I found the increased
swiftness of the flower Pikmin to be tremendous benefit also my diligent observation has recorded
instances in which flower Pikmin lost in battle have left seats behind this is why on days after
fierce battles I occasionally have new sproutlings okay well it'd be okay with inspection I have
time it's just they're fucking assholes and picked nine like the earliest time I was like can you do
it as late as possible and they were like sorry sorry I'm like what do you mean sorry sorry sorry
we have to do it as early as possible I'm like okay well like I can say fucking no
seedlings we're so back ASMR 98 no the ASMR was supposed to be in tourist time
but I forgot I had the freaking instruction so I would kind of need to do it now
controversial that would have to do it like right like enough
okay 15 right and then there's 15 in the space right we have the 30 we can move it now
and we can move it but they need to be able to win that fight as well
because they're going to move the plant across where that band pot is right they're going to jump
down this ledge with him I'm like 99% sure they are and they all need to get past this thing
did they not play test this like come on they're getting stuck you need to like come over a bit
I suppose I can tell these ones to be unresponsive and then these ones keep trying to come up
right come together math thank you for the 10 gifted memberships math 16 18 pythagoras theorem
um oh they're stuck stuck
okay that was more that was good right and then go to sleep and then the one I need no no no
they're fun okay I get why they have to like touch them and they'll follow you thing come over here
then come here I assume they're they're gonna fucking oh you know what we're not doing this one
first sorry we're not I'm sure this and they're getting stuck I need to be able to toss the red
ones to go fight or something okay come come across the water I think if I go near these
no they don't right water time
uh where was it is it this bit yeah it is this bit right go fix the bridge
yeah I think I'll send the red ones over to attack I like the one that's not doing his job
he's like bruv you did not pay me enough to do this thank you stash power for the tip and thank you
math again for the 10 gifted and buzzing bun for the 10 gifted as well I'm becoming a member that
was very gen that was kind of generous of you shit I don't know me make fuck around and make another
generation I don't know me make a gen two fuck around and find out my damn boy piss loud as fuck
are you are you pissing me right now I'd rather fucking eat a bit of the bridge
right use only to hurry up because I want that gem piece
quick quick quick quick faster faster feel like you pay us gen two in the making confirm no I'm not
pregnant just yet I showed she be she wasn't supposed to say out loud but I showed she be what
gen two look like so I admit it you caught me the concept art's finished you caught me
she you can't
keyword yet you could go get more reds and yellow to help on their side
I'm just they're almost on the bridge and I assume they're gonna and then I'll just tell them to
come finish it from the side and then I'll get them to grab that gem and then I'll get the reds
to beat up the monster at the top of that hill like I'll just throw them over at the monster
because there's so many reds it's a sacrifice I'm willing to make it is it's true
we need to wind and dine with me first yes just because the concept art is there it doesn't mean
that's been like you know started and all that and everyone has names as well actually I don't
know if that's of interest to you but they've been named I know I didn't have and she be gonna test
that I didn't fucking name them because we were struggling with two people one of the concept
arts had a really good first name but there's a very popular vtuber with that first name
um in an agency and I was like I'm not touching that with a 10-foot pole unless miraculously
that company announces they're they're fucking out fondal abysm you better start crying because
you're not getting fondal abysm again wait what time oh no I need to come this side
okay there we go right hurry up with this bridge I've been waiting for ages
congrats on your five beautiful slime girls absolutely fucking not and she be gonna test
that as well she will tell you what shenanigans right come on come on you will need to please be
30 I'm scared please be 30 I was 20 that's even better I'll take it that's even even better
okay gorgeous and then I'm gonna get and before they just cut across the water
they could have done that the whole time she be the fellow leaker confirmed actually feel
untrue though but yeah um she's been really interested in the development process I'm like
sure if you want to know about it I'll tell you like um kind of like at this start I would you
know disgust into a little bit and the girls were a bit like upset thinking I was ditching them I was
like I was trying to explain I was like well it took me a year to get you here like I wouldn't
talk about it if you don't so I did I stopped talking about it can they if I get red ones are
they gonna um you're beating up why are you beating that up you good boys stuff but you're
naughty boys right we've got more blues on the way I'm gonna harvest these yellows in case they
perish or something I don't know yesterday they were like right go go into your spaceship we're
doing blues only and then we're gonna take out a ton of freaking red for this fight
my reds are literally my veterans honestly if the only slime girl we need is mummy in a month
because I'd be I'd be slamming and inking and stuff shocking I actually I will say one thing
about this game I love that visually you can see Sagittarius ain't that a constellation this was a
gift from my son we have a son he must be very worried about me I have never recovered seven
out of thirty parts I need five more and I should be able to increase my ship's capabilities okay
oh wow I'm an idiot I'm an idiot I can throw them on the ledge walk around and then tell them to
attack the guy idiot idiot you can of course you can ledge throw them twat bag
absolute twat bag can we sneak around
absolute idiot right come around don't wake him up do you understand me
I said don't wake him up you idiot are you serious right now
are you serious he walked right into the enemy
are you serious how many did I just lose
as if that just happened they crave violence honestly
for my wee sweet innocent things you know that innocent are you right I'll let them move him
you come with me I heard not them moving the bugs body at the way right there and then we'll
increase the numbers of them again I'll give them a few extra so they hurry along we're midday now
but we've just picked up two parts today which is really good and we would need to fight our
way past to get that other one and it's getting a bit close to the end of the day
I don't know actually tell you what I'm gonna go exploring on my own because there was something
there was a show girl her name was Lola but that was 30 years ago when they used to have a show
oh waterlings okay waterlings break a barrier got it got it I'll see if I can grab some waterlings
to break this like right now we'll finish up this map maybe shock absorber this nifty okay
the my only if I play another map my only note is the ASMR is gonna be like one hour long I'll
do kissing and licking okay okay okay let's grab some waterlings I'm sure we have enough time
okay waterlings oh the bugs gonna be sacrificed actually you know what no I want
okay yeah let them do that and then bluelings
okay that's gorgeous gorgeous stunning I love it I love it separatelings
how many is that there a therial is enough to pick up stuff right surely we're not going
to be attacked by when we go on the other side of this wall surely surely surely cope them
right at least break down this barrier and then we'll see what's behind it because there's a part
behind here come on keep it up keep it up beat it up beat it up beat it up beat it up come on
there's therial is what was the map again this one yes there's something to the right but there's a
lot of space you strike a hard deal it's gonna be a yapping stream enemy real true just move the
ASMR moment no I moved around so much membership last week I feel really bad about it I feel really
bad okay I'm a bad drummer the title of the member stream is funny wait what did I say I
can't remember what I put I put up so many rooms like so quickly I listen to music when I put my
rooms up and sometimes I'll accidentally take the lyric of the song that I'm listening to and the title
I just like making things harder for myself clearly put my members boat down as completely happy
with last week I feel really bad I was like no this is getting cancelled not we're doing a
shorter stream not we're doing this we're doing that so I need a great stromer how dare you
hey no tentacles in cart oh I recall what I put now don't know right what is this bomblings
no it's not it's twattlings can you guys do this like super fast and break it so when we come back
tomorrow can you do this like super fast because we need to go to bed
whoa is it locked on to us
now I say break the wall but we're going straight back home
I'm bringing in all 100 of my recruits I'm not even kidding
how do we I assume I just throw 100 at them
oh my gosh that's a boy that's a boss fight all right
that thing is no joke be careful I can deplete my army
I want the doctor Robotnik is that it looks like a tank I assume I just send multiple colors at it
and it doesn't really matter
yeah we're getting a bit close to the end of the day either you guys break this barrier we're
going home yes that's like a bit more
if we get to that last thought I think I'm I'm taking her home
you might as well leave the blues won't break it our blues like weaker the glowing mouth is not
for sucking looks like it'll just suck them all up like a vacuum so I should send in reds
go home don't risk it right come on darlings
I'm not gonna take the shortcut whoa don't do that to me that scares me
everyone bed now do I make myself clear bed right we've got 30 blues not the worst could be worse
but not the worst you know reds get in my army of beautiful reds and you go blue I see you
randomly getting stuck on stuff I really do not have a lot right and then reds I'm gonna pop
you's out and send you away there's two big dogs over there now what the hell
okay go home
and there's no I don't even have time to see if I've left any behind
oh I just hope I've got 230 so yes mommy honking
red pickpins are the strongest check the map I mean it's too late I can't even go after we'll
have purples are in this game right they can breed amongst themselves oh no wait what do you mean
oh no no there's nothing left out you love their little voices let me be red ones deal 50% more
damage than other okay we're sending the red into the boss fight
there's more colors in the later variation games is what I'm trying to ascertain
goodbye thank you for hanging enjoy your dindins as well
right we'll do this boss fight and then I'm just praying
that sounds like a straw
and that sounds like the balutro background music I'm feeling a bit agamba coming on day seven
the pickpins always carry their prey on to the onion close observation indicates that taking
food pellets the onion of the same color result in a release of larger numbers of the sea
oh I was gonna say I was like I don't really seem to have any issues with the claws
okay red is up yellow maintained and blue went up a smidge
all right we're gonna I don't know how many we're gonna lose in this great war but
we'll find out right time for a war time for a war did someone say gambling let's go gambling
I have been in the balutron I'm so mad I don't like that membership stream
is that right we all reds all day baby all reds all day
I need a hundred of my best soldiers a hundred of my best soldiers come
I see a lot of flowers I see a lot of blue much I do see a few newbies which makes me nervous
I won their first experience on the field to be fucking insta there
oh for goodness sake I swear if anyone dies right now because this guy respawned I'm gonna be pissy
okay no one got hit
so what I need to tell them to come around
are you fighting nope stop just leave it just leave it just leave it come on 100 days
come on right defeat the grubs that are here
these are far too strong to be getting hurt by grubs I'm not gonna lie
okay
no no no don't don't start taking stuff back kill the grub kill the grub
okay right and then come is this what wait no wait what was there not a ledge I had to throw
them on shit I was back here I didn't even have to come this way right everyone don't get stuck
no stop stop I know you're hungry but not right now
you will you just you eat when you have done what you're supposed to do
there's only 97 how the fuck have I lost you
I don't know how I've lost some of you leave the beetle alone
she was no but mommy I'm starving you will you will have a feast after the battle is complete
how about that you will have a mighty feast
of the lakes you've never had before right and no one got stuck back here
I don't know I don't think anyone died though I think they're just being I don't know I'm not sure
fighting on an empty stomach extra motivation yes you'll be fed well right let me go around
and then I'll call you and then we're doing a motherfucking boss battle
our first boss battle surely this will go right
how about only come 97 I don't know how but I've lost a few
Pikmin hi you me I only saw one die yeah but it says a hundred have pulled out right now so
they got stuck on something and we're in I don't know where they are I'm sure the difference of three
uh picklings isn't going to cost us the battle right surely surely absolute raw cocaine
come on all right we're doing it we're doing it
just checking come on
come on brace yourself does boss music play is boss music gonna start off
97 who will win 97 well-behaved boys one big thingy mobile
eh come run don't
win
I need a yellow one to bomb its armor
why is there two of you following me I told you all to take a break
oh there's no way I need to the rocks
what it hurts itself with its own rock no it doesn't
oh goodness sake I guess I have to get a yellow one throw it over throw it up with a bomb and
then you can armor off are you drowning you fucking idiots stop it are you seriously drowning right
now oh just come there this is a failed attack oh my god just come we take up arms for our mother's
course bro literally to her and our house for love and glory with blade in hand charge
literally literally you just drowned we never even got to the boss battle
I don't think I can be ours going getting yellow ones out to try and nuke the armor off to
see if it'll work or how are we just back here oh cheeky things they came back and put away these
things I don't remember how to beat him
I assume what I'm supposed to do
is take a yellow I think you can clog the hole above its mouth with Pikmin wait I'm
supposed to just attack him with the army
am I actually
if I know what to do I'll attempt it but I'm not I don't know what to do
there are already a hundred Pikmin in the field
you just have to attack him head on
all right well we regroup right we'll regroup we'll regroup
we'll regroup her strength right up you get up you get one at a time
fill its holes jeez I'm somewhat of a whole filler myself bend over if a Pikmin is thrown
into its blowhole while it inhales it causes the be able to get stunned causing an opening
this is this is going to be a slaughter I'm just warning you this is an absolute slaughter
an absolute slaughter
right stop drowning please
okay
I'm 96 now I'll do now just have to do donkey right charge come around swing swing swing
beat him up fuck him up yes spank is ours spank is ours
okay we're half health nope right okay come come come come come come come come come come
listen to your mummy listen to your mummy listen to your mummy listen to your mummy
listen to your mummy right and go around go around yep yep come on
listen to you mummy listen to you mummy listen to you mummy listen to you mummy
right come back come back come back come back come back a fewer perished NO come back come back
I say right. I'm gonna throw in
No, no, no, no get shit. I just it oh
It's all coming apart it's all falling apart no, no, no, no, no no no no no no, no, no
My god, please
Please
Please no
No, no, no my baby. It's my baby's my baby
babies look at me look at me no come on come on you get that babies oh my gosh
no fucking give me that back Jesus take take this I don't know how much we need
for it 30 take it oh that was that was a slaughter that rock slide effect that was
insane you know how many do we need to take the body oh we need 30 for the body
as well at last my radiation canopy it turns the heart radiation a deep space
into soft infrared rays that are easy on the body I'll sleep like a baby once I
get this back in the ship oh my god radiation yet I'll have to inspect a
layer yeah no I never no okay oh my gosh my babies what I do with them I I guess
I'll come back like with more because we lost so many red to that like so many
red we lost they really want you to know about the radio I know I'm like I think
the spam so fast the game doesn't register stop spamming okay I'm get more
recruits I get and then we'll bring the body back replenish our supplies and I'm
happy to call it there we did one boss fight oh my god I only have 20 I brought
I'm gonna need a few more reds I think just a few well may I see can't feel my
tentacles mama why do I feel no it's getting dark I didn't know so many
we're gonna perish it was that rock slide attack if it didn't do that would be
fine look into the map for the lost ones before you forget them I should
radiation I'll have to inspect the lead to make sure it hasn't cracked I'll be
in for even more trouble if I have any radiation leave I've never recovered
nine out of 30 parts I mean we're actually doing all right
there's a red one stuck there and then the red ones are there that's fine
alright let me throw them over the ledge and then we can replenish you stop
getting stuck and we can replenish them with this boss's body I'll take you as
well
that's lucky you take that back you guys wait for me on the other side of the
wall I'll just and then nope you guys wait there
can't be our storm worries that I can't be bothered right come on right and then
you come with me right that's theory that's more than enough to move this
bug's body and then we'll see how many seeds come out of it we'll just put them
all on it so they hurry up because it's gonna be late thank you the bailer for
is that the maximum right you just come with me then unless you want to help a
bit more there you go are you so fast look at fast it's going
the spaceship built on the bodies of our fallen brethren it definitely feels
like that
come come come check the hudge nope right we're perfectly safe I've got everyone
accounted for
are you tired little picklings are you sleepyhead we're taking it oh taking it
to the red one let's see how many seeds
that replenish the fallen soldiers right right that replenished our numbers
really let them all go oh sorry I just caught those that were going up the
slide they worked hard it's time to feed them yes you're getting all the food
sees everyone you get food you get food you get food like 20% of our losses oh
god how many did I lose I'll find out in the afternoon after-action report I
wonder if we play one more game and pick up all the items in this area because
it's only this one now into I is right we'll play one more day and we'll get the
last item is there anything I can quickly harvest nah I don't trust it so
it's a little too little too near the end of the day right one more one more I'm
not addicted I swear I can quit at any time I want I'm not addicted to this
cute little management game type thing would you call a management game no
today no there is a some are there is a some are real and true
right everyone's in everyone's in okay we're fine can I like to skip the day
you have recovered 9 out of 30 okay had to finish the day can go to sunset I
don't know hydration check I'd call it a exploration puzzle yeah it's totally
not like supermarket something there I oh yeah I'm definitely playing the full
TCG game I feel looks like they've put loads of more stuff in it I had so much
fun playing that card opening shop thing I think it goes to sunset it advances to
the next day okay let's do that yes mm-hmm mm-hmm right we'll get the last
piece on this map then I can say I've 100% completed Pikmin on one level you
do love to see store I don't know I just find it I really enjoy like money up
kind of games where it feels satisfying like you start with like a rundown don't
like if I ever do get to making my own games don't be surprised if it's like
some rundown store and and you need to fix the business or else they're gonna go
bus type thing and then the game turns out you destroy like massive corporations
thank you I'll be here for all day I read every decent flint beetle this
creatures hypnotic reflatic body is quite hard given a good defense against
Pikmin attacks why then do the Pikmin chase them in such a friendly I wonder
if it will undergo any changes if I hit it directly with a Pikmin I don't I don't
know I was obviously my babies lost 44 in battle today oh my god look at that
red line depleted that's terrible literally chasing the shiny thing no
plate comes left behind yeah right one more we're gonna do the red one since
they're the best at battle again I'm so sorry to do this you got us killed
mom no I'm one of the 44 don't tag yourself as one of the dead frickin pink
wings honestly you're making more than you lose the sustainable I don't want to
sustain the death right we'll take a hundred out we'll make our way over to
that corner
right what they're already a hundred in field that just not go fast enough the
noises are so adorable wait oh I only have 97 to command but there's
apparently a hundred on the board god the fucking first ones are so fast
compared to the ones so can I just may I just do this oh please don't get caught
please don't get caught please don't get caught okay okay okay okay don't get
caught no don't fucking eat them right come come what are you see when you
randomly beat stuff up it freaks me out there's two piss right can you guys can
you sneak around are you skinny enough to do that without waking him up okay
let's beat this one up first since he's got his butt towards us no no no no no
no the we won't get the we want to oh it's a fucking massacre again I can't eat
okay I keep dealing with oh my god oh my god please please I need veteran
reeflings please how can I be so bad at this oh my gosh oh my gosh please just
get the item just get the item oh do not fall into the river I swear if any of
you fall into the river what did I just say oh my god what
oh my gosh I need warlings stop I need warlings stop falling into the river
I'm not gonna make it right I need to clear a path then I need to clear a
path for the waterlings to come in oh my god this is just a massacre and I need
to kill the two other dogs that are also there not stop it all my veterans are
going down how is this not killing them I have 50 I have 50 left I need to kill
this one right if I oh right I'm sending them to take all the bodies back though
I'm gonna get the warling okay okay it's taking a while to rotate that's good
right let's destroy this one too let's destroy this one and then we're good
okay need to go around it though round its arse and then attack and then it's
clear and I'll get the red ones to take all the big evil baddies home this was a
slaughter this was the worst day we've had so far I'm gonna just tell them to
take all these home take these okay take these two and take that one too right
and then we're gonna go get some bluelings that was awful 50 red 25 around 50
reds and 25 yellow and blues just in case I need them okay honestly I probably
should have right put those away bluelings you're time to shine I'm just
take it what can 30 come on then don't get stuck on the walls now thank you that
looks like it'll do come on come on babies yeah be with mommy you guys can
come to if you want but you're getting separated just so you know you get
chilled on everything you to get away from the edge right and separate
commands now don't wait what am I supposed to do is this not where the
item is why does it have a 10 on it then is it oh what it's a pathway what is it
doing just to move it out of the way okay stop edging the pickling
okay I'm not sure I want the red ones I feel like yeah they're just gonna come
back come back come back come back are you serious are you serious right now are
you freaking serious go replenish I'm being trolled so hard are you actually
fighting it are you's going for it I mean oh they've already got it quarter of
the way they are fuck it fuck it there's already quarter of the way they are just
go for it go beat it up surely this isn't gonna end in bloodshed oh surely
surely this is gonna be fine get out of its way get out of its way oh my god am
I even gonna have enough where's the I am oh wait no it's the same one sorry wait
is it the same one excuse me where the fuck is this where the fuck is this I am
child's game child's game by the way child's game by the way it's behind me
oh my god how is it behind me I'm on it it's in the flamingo
it's in the flamingo oh my god it's in the amni and ego get fucking reinforcements
are you fucking serious it's in the flamingo he ate it fat fucking bastard
honestly come on it's time I need every red little pickling I can get what the
fuck what the fuck I did not expect a boss fight I thought it was like one
boss per level I literally I can't believe that absolutely an eyelid I need max
numbers now I need all red blues I love you but you need users far too weak user
far too weak I think I'm just gonna have to throw the red on the chest like on
the ledge sorry not the chest there's a hundred pickling field is it cuz of these
ones brah I just want to finish one level the hat is the first boss is borrowing
if you feed him enough maybe he'll pop like a bullet don't say that but my
refunds good soldiers fight till their last breath thank you stash forever
that's so cruel I need all the red you guys are really strong I don't know
where the others are maybe they're still alive copium maybe they're just having a
wee break oh my god he's just he's the only survivor I'm gonna need you to go
up oh fucking attack it don't just stand there oh you you you think you you
eat no stop attacking the fricking random are they gonna make it across the
bridge without dying is my motherfucking request
come on now no one gets stuck at the bridge do I make myself clear right
line up redlings redlings just march across the bridge don't fall in they're
just gonna have to go for it there's no way out there's no way right okay do we
get the piece but that wasn't it
uh redlings come on stop shaking them off they don't know what to do when you
shake them off please he's quarter health oh my god we're not gonna make it
unless they get like a fucking tons of tallywax in we're not even 50% there I've
got like eight of them left I got 15 I'm trying to avoid them getting eaten by
like going around in a circle around it from the back but he's like picking them
off his body to eat
kids game by the way and he instantly goes under the ground to knock them off
alright so when I get the jump on it it fucking better me but when you get the
jump on it oh my god we're not gonna make it no don't randomly fucking pick
things up please just go stop it stop stop picking things up and attack the
fucking boss where is it freaking oh would you like me to pick that up no
hey you're a veteran oh I'm literally gonna go down cuz you I'm literally
gonna go there I need a bird's-eye view of this motherfucker I think we may be
able to do it no unless they get grabbed like that can I like whack them to I
literally can't do anything to help them I'm only I'm on one shot as well the
picklings are also on one shot I don't know if I can like distract him like the
AI to pick on me instead oh come on pick on me instead not them come on I have
three a four life I just need them to get on no I'm not gonna make it oh come
on he's one hell I don't even know if he stays dead I even know if he's gonna stay
dead I don't know AI look at me AI look at me what do you mean hurry up I'm
not the one fighting I'm not the one putting a boss fight in a kid's game
that needs to be free and perfect I was not even responding now oh yeah that's
fine I didn't want to win the fight anyway I've got one left
and that respawned okay well I don't I don't know what to tell you I don't know
what to tell you it's all good I don't know what I did so horrifically wrong
either you should just replay the game they're re now I'm gonna call it their
chief that was I don't know what I was supposed to do I'm a call it there I'm
gonna prepare for my ASMR stream cuz bruv yeah restart those now fuck that we
we can I'm not take the L in that one that was the worst command an army I
could have done and most of your Pikmin drought literally thank you for
coding in that bridge that I unlocked and maybe code them not to drown when we
can all walk past it together
but then you won't get any back because it all says I have really bad news I have
terrible news I have really shocking news and you're not ready for it I left one
behind as well to get eaten reflect we'll do better next time yes next time
we'll do better they all vanished at me as well fallen prey to the planets not
eternal creatures an ugly thought perhaps that's why they follow me into the
atmosphere I'm starting to grasp the cycles of life on this planet well that
was a fucking slaughter and a half we actually have more yellow than we do
red now fuck it out fuck it out right save do not touch the memory card or the
paragon riparoni pepperoni it was nice having news when I had no a smart no
I'm gonna prepare for ASMR now and we aren't coming back to this at all one of
you said it one of you said it I wasn't gonna say it but one of you said it and
I am gonna go get a cup of tea and quickly prepare for my membership ASMR
stream it'll be very short because some inspections very quickly but lol well
one of you it wasn't me that said it but one of you said it okay so many fall a
good effort thanks for leading us to the weird planet creature did you like the
game better than blinks I did yes it was it's really satisfying when it's
satisfying but when whatever that just happened just happened yeah no you're
done next time we flings next time yep we're not coming you want me to play it
can we just watch someone else play it and then I'll commentate over it and
pretend like I know what I'm doing I feel like I suck the picklings did their
best they did right well see is Azura is not back yet
why I keep going into these games being like this child's game is going to be
so easy the child's game just absolute obliteration it's okay to suck I know
that's why I focus on swallowing mostly
is there any of you? not really. Juno's up we'll redirect into Juno
because Juno is nice to me alright nobody's on until Marisa is I'll I'll
redirect into Juno so thanks for collabing with us there's something new
under your art tag that may be useful for the ASMR my wholesome art tag or my
naughty ones I swear if it doesn't display I'm gonna cry the gun
wait someone raked a reefling oh my god and then there's me sitting down wait
why did I get someone oh my god wait but the gun one's so funny there's a gun
one did she be cancelled today's stream yeah she's not very well well grim you
into someone who will enjoy playing difficult games for a challenge that'll
be an awful lot of fucking gun and then grim and that's all I'm saying thanks
for the stream yeah have fun with Azura I will thank you
he he he I'm retweetin the fucking gun one wait but someone got reeflings rigged
you have spiral eyes as well where's mommy the reeflings come to life
illustrated by commons in entertainment a rig by me and conceived by strong it
can't be downloaded for the coffee link oh my god I can be a reefling stop I
want to roleplay as you in a member stream mommy touch my tentacle
drew the sexy Scottish Squidward Beach River I'm a cuttlefish you'd like me to
sit on you like this wouldn't you down straight hold on let me reply to it down
straight squid who you calling a squid I ain't no squid oh my gosh wait but
it's a reefling BRB role-playing role-playing as a helpless are I can't
put our wordable into where I'll get cancer BRB role-playing as a helpless
reefling right now right now for real for real a pillow green heart I love it
look at your wee tentacles overlapping that's so adorable and you got your
little hip noise are you squiddin me octopus no I'm a
cuttlefish someone said in response to me leaking my schedule I'm pretty sure
you'd explode if you had to stop yapping at chat for an extended period of time I
just combust you know what I think they're like oh the self-combust theory
we're all a personal just self-combust shut the fuck up shut the fuck up people
do not combust the human body cannot fucking turn into flames on its own
shut the fuck up I want to see that shit ever again I remember my mom watching a
stupid documentary on it I was just like shut up stop talking sorry that was
really random like you meant they're called the struggle snuggles some people
spontaneously no it's real don't stop it better not be I swear I'm gonna be so
angry if it's real is self-combusting theory real I better say no I swear the
scientific consensus that incidents which might appear subcontinuous
combustion did in fact have external sources of ignition thank you
bro I'm not I'm not believing that theory I hate that theory so much whenever
oh do you know humans can randomly self-combust no they fucking can no
that's not how humans work that's how bodies work so I got fucking gunpowder
sitting in my left ear fuck off sorry I hate that's complete tangent it upsets
me so much when I hear that theory don't don't come to me with such theories
no your combust into flames like Goku a lot of comes from static electricity when
you have a cheeky Indian and holding the gas it right enough
bro yeah combust all the time yeah I bet you bust all the time sounds like an
excuse for a secret heart attack say strongy have you ever heard of quantum
tunneling I don't know should we do it I mean theoretically the probability
isn't zero for the human body to do it for your way like 90% wet cells to do it
so I know I should be praying plate prep preparing for ASMR making a cup of tea
right now if they don't come fish like Pokemon you go that's gonna be your other
nickname
throne so right as always when I redirect into someone someone else I'm
redirecting into dinner please be respectful please be an extension of
me no that doesn't mean be like me cuz you know how inappropriate I am okay
right I love you please enjoy dinner and I give you kiss on face okay if you
remember give me five minutes and I'll put up the ASMR membership stream okay
I see I'll give you a kiss for every pickling we had and we had like 200
thank you typical nation for the tip as well but right say hi to Jenna for me
I'll be up in five minutes okay